now protests in Senegal have continued
for a third day
it follows the conviction of opposition
leader Usman sonko he was sentenced to
two years and the charge of corrupting
the youth fifteen people have been
killed and the Army has been deployed to
contain unrest Nicholas Hart reports now
from the capital Dhaka
this is Dakar safe p aceful and
prosperous home to wealthy Senegalese
and foreigners
and this is also the car the poor
neighborhoods where young people are
fighting with security forces after a
court sentenced opposition leader Usman
to two years in prison his supporters
say it's a fight against Injustice
employed by president makisal to
eliminate his opponent ahead of next
year's elections
we need to fight we won't stop President
makisal is responsible for this we won't
let him get his way we won't let him
stay in power or detain Usman sonko we
are not going to stand for it for them
sonko is the voice of the young and
voiceless challenging the rich and
powerful he's calling for an uprising
against the government several people
have been killed in the violence
including members of the security forces
the governments say some officers were
shot dead by protesters for people like
Mustafa 5 sonko is not the right leader
is divisive and he's dividing our
country he's manipulating the young who
are unemployed and frustrated
presidents always calling for calm and
dialogue meanwhile the Army has been
deployed to protect businesses and Banks
from looting
so much of the unrest is fueled by
poverty and lack of jobs well the
economy is booming under President
makisal people in this neighborhood feel
left out and ignored
president Sal has brought unprecedented
foreign investment thanks to the
discovery of oil and gas but sonko
accuses his government of corruption and
leaving the young behind who are now
taking to the streets to get their
voices heard
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Dakar
well earlier we spoke to Aliso he's the
Senegalese Minister for culture and
historical Heritage he says that the
sentencing of Usman song it was a purely
judicial matter which the opposition
leader has politicized
this is not a political decision it's a
Judiciary decision he's condemning for
two years in jail imprisonment he has to
serve two years in jail who is a fine of
one thousand dollars so then with the
following decision is a Judiciary one is
that political one what is important he
wanted trust for Judiciary problem if
your political matter and challenge so
then but as you know somebody who is
condemned he can use all digital City
tools and measures which is lawyers as
well that if the decision is taken it
cannot prevent the Judiciary and I mean
the the prison services to systems to
put it where he must be